another reaction video ladies and
gentlemen
yes we're gonna say it in every video I
know is it because we're wearing the
same clothes yes and this is where the
intro starts boom it's got magic
[Music]
all right this is if Jesus never called
himself God
why why do Christians worship Him
that's a great question I think it's
legit all right let's see I don't know I
will
I'll say my shahada if this is a good
argument okay let's see all right
do you think as a Christian I blaspheme
by saying like God became man I think as
a as a Muslim who knows about
Christianity yeah I think Christians
should believe that you blasphemed I
think if you look at the original sorry
I had to stop it there as a CR as a
Muslim oh
are we boring you no are you sure yes
because we can do this I'm good you're
good continue all right
as a Muslim who knows what Christians
believe he says that Christians should
think that you blaspheme so he knows
more than us
uh apparently yes he knows what we need
to do as a Muslim
that's crazy
so Muslims know more about Christianity
than Christians I am I I bet you
he could have quoted John 3 16. shut up
a
Regional Church before Constantine uh
constantly and these guys were
monotheistic they never ascribed Christ
to be a part of God they never ascribed
him to be divine they never worship
Christ right so I'm saying as per the
early Christians your last few
can you uh whose phones or can you go on
your phone your phone it's about to die
it's about to die just help while we're
doing this good Lord there's no way
go on your phone as well you got your
phone won't you no I got a million views
all right I want you to type in the
search bar early church fathers on the
deity of Christ
okay you search early church fathers say
Jesus is God okay okay let's see here
because he said the early Christians
even before Constantine so Constantine
is 300 and 300s so before that
closer to the time
the early church fathers they they were
purely monotheistic they did not claim
that Jesus is God what is this all right
here we go Irene is writing in ad120
between 81 20 and A.D 190. okay he's
quoting a guy named polycarp who was a
disciple of John who wrote the Gospel
interesting okay so irenaeus is quoting
polycarb right irenaeus was a student of
polycar polycarp was a student of job
all right we got that John polycarp
arenais so irenaeus is quoting polycarp
and this is what he says that polycarp
said he says now may the God and father
of our Lord Jesus Christ
and the Eternal high priest himself the
Son of God Jesus Christ Build You Up in
faith and truth and in all gentleness
and in all freedom from anger and
forbearance and steadfastness and
patient endurance and Purity and may he
give to you a share and a place among
his Saints and to us with you and to all
those under Heaven who will yet believe
in our Lord and God Jesus Christ and in
his father who raised him from the dead
this is a second century Church Father
right so that's polycarb that's irenaeus
quoting polycarb teaching that Jesus is
God why would this Muslim say that there
are no or the early Christians none of
them ascribe deity to Christ none of
them said that Jesus was God that's what
he says why would he say why would he
say that I just want to know that's
tough maybe he didn't come across that
lack of knowledge Ignatius was a bishop
of Antioch at the same time as polycard
so now we're talking about Ignatius here
so in the letter to the Ephesians this
is what he writes for our God Jesus the
Christ was conceived by Mary according
to God's plan straight to the point
in 19 Verse 3 he States right letter to
his to the Ephesians he says
consequently all magic and every kind of
spell were dissolved the ignorance so
characteristic so characteristic and
Wick of wickedness vanished and the
ancient kingdom was abolished when God
appeared in human form to bring the
newness of eternal life
so we got polycarb we got Ignatius
right wow okay that's two for two
who else we got here Justin Martyr hey
Justin what's up with you man
Justin Martyr dialogue of trifle then I
replied reverting to the scriptures I
shall Endeavor to persuade you that he
who is said to have appeared to Abraham
and to Jacob and to Moses and who is
called God is distinct from him who made
all things numerically I mean not
distinct in will for I affirm that he
has never at any time done anything
which he who made the world above whom
there is no other God has not wished him
both to do and to engage himself with so
what he says here is that he is distinct
from the father but not distinct in will
they share the same will and they share
the same Essence that's what Justin
Martyr is is teaching right although
they are distinct in personhood that's
crazy right
what does he say
and that Christ being Lord and God
the Son of God and appearing formally in
power as man and Angel and in the glory
of fire as at the bush
so also was manifested at the Judgment
executed on Sodom has been demonstrated
fully by what has been said
just a martyr irenaeus polycarp Ignatius
early church about this guys
that's right then why are you always
lying why you always lying
oh my God stop freaking lying
next video
[Music]